for as long as I remember I've loved
mathematics actually it's not a hundred
percent true
I've loved mathematics for all but a
two-week period in senior high school I
was top of my class and we were about to
start the extension maths course I was
really excited about this brand-new
topic coming up complex numbers
I like complex my teacher was priming us
for the concepts is some questions about
square roots square root of 9 3 square
root of 256 16 - easy then she asked the
trick question what about the square
root of negative 1 of course we were all
over it come on this we all know you
can't take the square root of the
negative that's true in the real world
she said but in the complex world the
square root of a negative 1 is the
imaginary number I
that day my entire mathematical world
came crashing down on me imaginary
numbers seriously
but mathematics is a source of truth
please don't go abstract on me I would
have studied art if I wanted to play
with imaginary numbers this is extension
math let's get back with a program she
didn't and over the next couple of weeks
I reluctantly performed meaningless
calculations finding imaginary solutions
to quadratic equations but then
something amazing happened
we began finding elegant solutions to
real-world problems we previously had no
answers to starting with the complex
world of imaginary numbers so some
mathematician 500 years ago decides to
have some fun and make up these
imaginary numbers and because of that we
can now derive these amazing identities
with applications in the real world in
fields like electrical engineering Wow
I gained a whole new level of
appreciation for mathematics and after
my brief mistrust I was now in love with
the subject more than ever
Frances sue the mathematician sums it up
beautifully
when he says we study mathematics for
play for beauty for truth for justice
and for love but if you ask a student
today you probably hear a different
story
you might hear difficult and boring and
they might be right about difficult but
it's certainly not boring in fact I'd
say being difficult to master is part of
what makes it beautiful because nothing
worth doing is easy so we need students
to stick around long enough through the
difficult parts to appreciate the beauty
when it all ties together much like I
did for that brief couple of weeks in
high school unfortunately our school
systems we move students through
mathematics in a lockstep process so
those who fall a little behind find it
near impossible to ever
catch up and appreciate that beauty but
why is this a problem why should we care
well today more than ever our world
needs every citizen to be skilled in
mathematics with the advent of
artificial intelligence and automation
many of the jobs we see today
will either not exist or be transformed
to require less routine work and more
analysis and application of expertise
but we're not producing the extra
mathematic students to fill these new
roles this graph shows a number of
students taking standard mathematics and
advanced mathematics over a period of 20
years in Australia it's clear that while
we have demand for mathematic skills
rapidly increasing supply is in steady
decline to put things in perspective
half of the students completing high
school today in Australia and not
prepared to understand any argument
about rates of change in data in this
digital age we're fake news can
influence election results this is very
concerning let me give you a concrete
example let's take a closer look at that
graph can everyone see what I've done
there this dress my point if you can let
me show you it now with the vertical
axis starting at 0 where it should be
there you see it now right it's the
exact same data but I've manipulated the
representation to influence you and
that's cool that's my job up here but in
all seriousness unless we do something
to drastically improve student
engagement with mathematics will not
only have a huge skills shortage crisis
but a fickle population easily
manipulated by whoever can get the most
air time so what's the solution there
are a lot of things we have to do we
need curriculum reform we need our best
and brightest encouraged to become
teachers we need to put an end to
high-stakes tests and instead follow a
mastery based learning approach but all
these things take time
and I'm impatient see I've been thinking
about this for eight years now and ever
since I left my job as a derivative
trader to build a web application to
help students learn mathematics today
our app is used by schools across the
globe and we're seeing big improvements
for students who use the program
regularly but here's the thing we're
only seeing it for students who used the
program regularly and most of them don't
so after years of developing and
refining the application our biggest
challenge was not so much product
related our biggest challenge was
motivating students to want to work on
their gaps in understanding you can
imagine in today's attention economy
we're competing against Facebook
snapchat and Playstation to try and get
these students time so we went back to
the drawing board and start to think
about how we could make it worthwhile
for students to spend some of their
attention budget on their education we
tinkered with gamification elements like
points badges and avatars and we'd see a
temporary spike in engagement but things
would go back to normal as soon as the
novelty wore off then one day my
co-founder Alvin came across a study of
students in Chicago led by the
behavioral economist Steven Levitt where
they paid students who improved on their
test scores started to tell me about
some of the things they tested foreign
interesting findings they had for
instance they found that incentivizing
students for inputs like effort worked a
lot better than incentivizing for
outputs like test scores they found that
for younger students you could win them
over with the trophy but for all the
students really needed cash and the
amount of cash mattered $10 was good
$20 even better but perhaps most
importantly they found that the rewards
had to be instant rather than promised
at a later date they went as far as to
give the students $20 and say touch it
feel it smell it
it's all yours but if you fail I'm gonna
take it back and that worked really well
I immediately got excited about the
possibilities of implementing this in
our program but once the excitement
settled down there are a few concerns
that crept in our minds firstly was this
ethical secondly how would we fund this
thing and finally would the results be
sustained if the students were no longer
paid now let's look at the ethical part
first I'm a bit of a mathematical purist
so I'd be one of the first people to say
that we should study mathematics for the
sake of mathematics remember foreplay
for beauty for truth for justice and for
love not for money as I struggled with
this I came to see that while it's the
way I look at mathematics now it's only
because I started it long enough to
appreciate it it's very difficult to
tell a student struggling with
mathematics today to work hard for a
payoff in the distant future and it's
not so much bribery that's at work here
because I could bribe students by
telling them about my big bonuses in my
derivative trading days as a reward for
doing well at maths but it doesn't pay
off for a very long time so it's
practically ignored behavioural
economists call this hyperbolic
discounting and Leavitt goes as far as
to say that all motivating power
vanishes when rewards are handed out
with a delay so from a purely economic
point of view if we don't use immediate
incentives we are under investing in
student outcomes
I took heart from that and came to see
that as a society were actually quite
used to financial incentives whether it
be by the government by employers or at
home for instance many parents would pay
their children and allowance or pocket
money for doing chores in the house so
it wasn't really all that controversial
as I thought about that it started to
answer that second question of how we're
going to fund this naturally parents are
the most invested in their children's
education
so let's charge them a
weekly subscription fee to use our
program but if the students complete
their weekly mass goal we'll refund the
subscription amount directly into the
child's bank account we chose three
exercises completed over a one-week
period for a ten dollar reward that way
we're incentivizing effort rather than
performance over a short enough period
and with a substantial enough payout for
the students to care now I remember when
I first told my wife about this new
business model if she had any doubt left
that I've gone completely mad that
pretty much confirmed it for her
she said to me mo you realize that if
everybody does their homework what you
want you're not going to make any
revenue which you don't want right
business model I see it it's more like
an anti business model it's it's free if
you use it but you pay if you don't now
I knew from experience that not
everybody in the country was gonna jump
on and do their math homework every week
and if they did sure we'd go bust pretty
quickly but hey we would have solved the
country's masculist
as a company we've always run a double
bottom line looking to both make a
return for investors as well as improve
student outcomes we know that our path
to long-term profitability is through
improving student outcomes
so our dual objectives should never be
at odds so we're always looking to make
our product decisions around helping
students reach their weekly mass goal
effectively ensuring that they get paid
and not us now you must be wondering how
is this crazy business model going
you'll be glad to know we're still in
business we've been testing this now for
the last five months on just our
personal home uses in Australia before
we think about rolling it out to schools
and here are the early results the green
represents students who are completing
their weekly maths goal and the red
those who are you can see a lot more
completing their homework than not in
fact as our user base has grown we found
the percentage to be pretty
steady at around 75% so on average we
receive our weekly subscription fee once
every four weeks and the other three
weeks we're rewarding the students now
of course we're leaving some money on
the table here but guess what it turns
out these students are 70 percent more
engaged than students not on the rewards
program check from a business
perspective they're less likely to churn
and more likely to refer friends so
we're hoping to trade off a lower
revenue per user for a bigger and more
engaged user base check and check
now for that final question would they
keep coming back if they were no longer
paid mathematics is so much more than
just a subject you study at school it's
a human endeavor it's what helps us to
understand the world around us and the
more you know the more you want to know
so yes we've triggered initial
engagement with a financial reward but
in the long run the money won't matter
anymore because in the long run the
wonder of mathematics will be the
incentive and understanding it will be
the reward thank you
[Applause]